grab your guns because telltale games
the latest title has you leading the
guardians of the galaxy through their
adventures star-lord and the rest of the
gang returns in the first of this five
part episode xseries so follow their
journey through space and also subscribe
to the gamespot youtube channel for more
coverage we must finish what we started
I cannot delay any longer my leader
demands it I don't know what the hell is
blabbing on about sorry about earlier i
was very very very drunk we do not want
an apology huh we you have something I
desired
the Eternity Forge and since jinza could
not retrieve it earlier I must take it
myself I will not fail you again no you
dated some crazy but this is a whole
nother level hey rocket clock shut up
fair enough shut up and start fighting
back I'll protect the money victory
Oh
[Music]
that's mine no no hey hey
we have what we came for rocket we need
the ship edges it down gotta take a many
can't wait they're getting away I'm
coming with you there's only one pack
allow me to fight beside you star-lord I
killed Thanos I can kill some measly
blue warriors size of that warship you
can't fight your way through that take
me and I'll never even know we were
there let us paint her ship red with
blood from the inside Gamora you're with
me as you wish kill all the tree for me
star-lord if you do not I shall never
forgive you
Peter
Peter Gomorrah kind of busy rocket you
need to know this that ship your head
towards its cream anyway someone named
paulo the accuser crazy but there was
destroyed
wait wrong that ship those people should
exist well I'm looking right at right
behind you
Thanks anytime
looks clear let's get moaning uh would
be nice if you'd fill me in here
yesterday that relic was nothing to you
I mean you drank out of it now you're
blindly chasing it into a cream portion
what aren't you telling me hey I don't
understand back I'm in Olano it showed
me something uh a vision I was back home
and it felt so real my mom told me to
come to find her you saw your dead mom
in a dream we don't know what this thing
is it could be affecting you honestly
I'm just as confused as you are
confusion or not that relic is dangerous
who knows what else that's capable of
look we just need to get the relic back
all right Peter whatever you say
huh what the hell those are pictures of
you
this is more to in worship and we're
sure they're actually really dead right
the Kree or a technologically advanced
species science
those lives are cream but I can't make
out what it says I can't much better
[ __ ] performing at six percent crew
efficiency that there's a lot of dead
folks
come on the precipitation has got to be
there which means that's where the relic
is halle would be expecting a direct
attack we need to find in there without
pc
to access me to do six diseases fault
now
whoa my bad they can't get any deader I
guess hey Nora
I'm game if you are perfect
lead the way keep moving and stay quiet
huh you're the one who's talking what
did you say
someone has deactivated the spaces fault
our new womens
we must fight they cannot be fun
did you hear that
you